[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur rt
france pour ce nouveau numéro de la
grande interview aujourd'hui on est
heureux de recevoir anne sophie joly
présidente du collectif national des
associations d'obèses pour parler vous
l'aurez compris d'obésité un problème de
santé publique qui concerne aujourd'hui
17% des français
anne sophie joly bonjour bonjour merci
d'être avec nous aujourd'hui sur arte
france alors on va parler tout de suite
du sujet qui fait l'actualité la
grossophobie avec cette une de télérama
censuré par instinct g quand vous
apprenez cette nouvelle qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
désolant affligeant parce que ce que je
vais dire la majeure partie des gens ne
savent pas c'est que l'obésité génère 18
autres maladies derrière style apnées du
sommeil diabète cancer l'hypertension
artérielle infertilité hommes et femmes
donc en fait
est-ce qu'on peut s'amuser à balayer ça
d'un revers de manche
je suis pas sûr est-ce que juste parler
de différences des gens parce que
corporellement on déborde d'amour ça
dérange
ça peut déranger bien sûr tout le monde
n'est pas obligé d'aimer par contre que
ça génère des maladies ça ça me dérange
mois un peu plus que ce soit stigmatisée
comme ça donc
donc voilà je pensais qu'en 2020 on
avait des connaissances beaucoup plus
poussé que la formation court à droite à
gauche en permanence et qu'on est soi
disant assoiffés d'information de bonnes
informations
est ce qu'au final on va discriminer des
gens parce qu'ils ont corpulence qui est
différente
maintenant est ce que des gens qui sont
encore plus lents sont automatiquement
bonne santé à tous en tout cas un
instant t peut-être mais un instant t +
+ pas forcément et que c'est pas moi qui
le dit c'est l' oms donc c'est
l'organisation mondiale de la santé et
que c'est un fléau mondial et que c'est
pour ça qu effectivement se bat alors
cette actualité 1
cette censure de la part du réseau
social
ça m'a permis de parler un petit peu
plus de 7 grossophobie est ce que c'est
quelque chose que vous ressentez depuis
longtemps dans l'air en france c'est
quelque chose qu'on vit au quotidien
c'est c'est de la discrimination
lorsqu'on veut chercher un travail
on va vous dire où on va pas vous dire
qu'on va vous regarder avec un petit
sourire en coin en disant mais alors
comment vous dire vu votre corpulence là
je suis pas bien sûr que finalement vous
rentrez dans les gold standard de la
société et j'ai pas envie voilà je
préfère quelqu'un qui soit qu' une autre
corpulence soit mais intellectuellement
et humainement ça ne change strictement
rien il y avait un sociologue qui avait
chez qui avait fait des études qui
expliquait que finalement une personne
obèse il fallait qu'elle ait deux
diplômes en école supérieure en plus
d'une autre pour arriver au même niveau
c'est à dire que finalement vous arrivez
avec quelqu'un qui enfin deux personnes
qui ont un bts une personne obèse une
personne qui n'est pas obèse mais
finalement c'est celle qui sera pas
obèse qui sera pris et si vous avez
quelqu'un qui a un master 2 qui est
obèse est quelqu'un qui ajuste un bts à
celle qui a un bts a plus de chance
d'être prise que celle qu'un master 2
donc là on est dans dans la démence à
mes yeux on est hors sujet l'obésité est
reconnu par l' oms comme étant une
maladie à partir d'un certain stade et
dès l'instant où vous effectivement
déclencher des maladies associées
donc il va falloir commencer
sérieusement à l'entendre parce que on a
de plus en plus de personnes qui sont
atteints d'obésité
on a de plus en plus d'enfants qui sont
en baisse de plus en plus tôt un enfant
qui déclenche une obésité
dans ses premières années à 75 80 % de
chances de rester obèses à l'âge adulte
et et combien de chances de déclencher
une maladie une comorbidité comme un
diabète ou une hypertension artérielle à
30 ans donc pas voilà pour moi ça sort
du cadre ce qu'on veut c'est garder les
gens le plus longtemps possible en bonne
santé
faire de la prévention faire des
politiques de santé
ce que hrw effectivement ce gouvernement
là avec la feuille de route obésité sur
lequel nous on a la chance de faire
partie du comité de direct
donc on y travaille le collectif existe
depuis 17 ans moi ça fait 20 ans que je
fais du bénévolat c'est pas dans mon
intérêt c'est dans l'interêt tous
et quand vous voyez les gens qui
reviennent nous voir en disant mais ému
je suis heureuse parce qu'effectivement
j'ai pu être soigné est en de bonnes
conditions
j'ai pu trouver les bons professionnels
j'ai pu être considérés ma maladie est
considérée comme quelque chose de réel
ça c'est important parce que ça ne se
soigne pas à coup de spots télé ça ne se
soigne pas à coups de livres ça se
soigne avec des véritables médecins qui
sont formés en faculté de médecine et
qui ont fait des débuts d'aidé y eut en
chirurgie en médecine enfin si une
pathologie à part entière vous en
parliez tout à l'heure ça touche de plus
en plus de personnes en france 33
millions de français atteints de
surpoids et d'obésité
c'est énorme tout simplement pour qu'on
comprenne bien qu'est ce que c'est
qu'être obèses alors vous avez si vous
tapez obésité ou si vous tapez indice de
masse corporelle ça va être votre taille
sur le poids au carré donc on va
calculer on va rentrer votre taille
on va rentrer votre poids et vous allez
rentrer entre guillemets dans dans des
choses un peu un peu droite qui sont
effectivement maigreur normalité
surpoids obésité classe 1 classe de kas
3 et au delà effectivement danny mc de
40 vous êtes en obérant morbidité donc
en fait à taux de mortalité beaucoup
plus élevés et de déclencher des
maladies
donc l'argent vie diront on passe dans
la ligne rouge de votre espérance de vie
donc c'est c'est comment on peut réussir
à se dire bon bah voilà je suis comme ça
déjà arrêté la prise de toi en soi c'est
déjà une victoire
et après en fonction de ce que vous êtes
et depuis depuis votre enfance depuis
votre est ce que votre vos parents vos
grands parents avaient un problème de
poids
est ce qu'à un moment donné il y a eu
quelque chose dans votre vie où il ya eu
un décès il ya une séparation il ya eu
perte de travail des accidents de vie
qui ont fait que
effectivement votre corps a été en
réaction ce qui est logique ce qui est
logique mais après voilà c'est comment
on peut aider les gens à poser à les
sécuriser et l ordi rumba voilà en fait
vos habitudes alimentaires était celle
ci mais vos dépenses énergétiques
en termes d'activité physique et je
précise bien activité physique et c'est
quoi c'est déjà commencé à marcher c'est
se balader c'est pas nécessairement
aller dans un club c'est avoir le corps
en permanence en mouvement et avoir le
corps en mouvement fait qu'effectivement
vous allez brûler des toxines vous allez
brûler des calories et et que même si
vous voyez votre poids ne change pas ce
que la jouait les photos devant moi la
masse musculaire pèse plus lourd que le
gras donc si vous transformez votre
graisse en muscles mais sait c'est que
du bonheur parce que en plus vos muscles
on vous demande et de l'énergie ben
voilà et vous rentrez dans une spirale
qui va être vertueuse métaboliquement
parlant vous parliez tout à l'heure de
prévention qu'est ce qui est fait
aujourd'hui concrètement en france et
est ce que c'est assez alors ce qui est
fait en france
en fait pas grand-chose parents chose
pour pour pas dire rien en fait on est
en retard aussi à barberaz certains les
les pays nordiques ils ont 25 ans d'
avance mais c'est une autre mentalité
et puis et puis après c'est va
l'apprendre prendre pied sur la réalité
du terrain sur la problématique du
terrain si je fais juste un petit focus
l'obésité coûte à l'état 22 milliards
d'euros à l'année rien que l'obésité les
pathologies chroniques toutes
pathologies chroniques coûte 170
milliards à l'année au delà de ce que ça
peut coûter à l'état
moi ce que je vois c'est ce que ça coûte
aux individus en terme psychologique en
terme médical en termes sociétale en
termes professionnels et ça ça fait des
dégâts considérables
donc l'intérêt que nous avons tous au
milieu de tout ça c'est comment rester
en bonne santé le plus longtemps
possible
comment faire en sorte qu'on ait une
alimentation la plus saine possible que
nous pouvons transformer nous mêmes
comment on peut avoir une activité
physique
comment ça peut s'inscrire au sein des
villes c'est un travail des maires de
france
les restaurations au sein des écoles est
capital la restauration que vous pouvez
avoir dans les sociétés privées aussi
elle est importante
tout ce qui peut être fait c'est pas moi
je peux passer soeur 2 mondial c'est
faux ça commence chez soi tout de suite
maintenant j'aimerais qu'on parle aussi
un peu de vous de votre engagement ça
fait plus de 15 ans que vous avez créé
le collectif national des associations
d'obèses ça fait plus de vingt ans que
vous vous engager personnellement et
bénévolement
qu'est ce qui vous a tout simplement
poussé à vous à vous engager
c'était sur mon lit d'hôpital je venais
d'être opéré et je me suis dit j'ai
réussi à avoir des informations d'ordre
médical parce qu'à l'époque je travaille
en presse médicale mais je me suis dit
tous ceux qui ont besoin d'informations
et qui n'en n'ont pas ils font comment
et là je me suis dit machine tu a
bénéficié d'informations
tu a bénéficié de ton réseau maintenant
redonne aux autres voilà donc je me suis
dit il faut que ce que mes souffrances
et c'est pas que mes souffrances sais
les souffrances de tout à chacun de tout
le monde et je me suis dit ça voilà donc
j'ai mon côté saint bernard puis remonte
à la surface et je me suis dit je ne
peux pas juste garder ça pour moi et je
redonne et quel bilan vous tiré de
vingt ans de combat c'est mitigé parce
que il ya à la fois des choses ont
énormément bougé on a eu un plan
présidentiel le plan obésité sous la
tutelle du monsieur sarkozy on a eu les
états généraux de l'alimentation sous la
tutelle de monsieur macrophages rcd gros
gros truc a enfin on a été à la guerre
faut pas rêver c'est moi il m'est arrivé
d'être plusieurs fois couchée sur la
table en train de lever le doigt en
disant je ne lâcherai rien donc voilà
mais on avance on avance
il faut mettre tout le monde autour de
la table et être en capacité d'écouté de
trouver où se trouvent les problèmes et
où sont les solutions et se dire voilà
chacun y va avec ses spécificités
le tronc commun il doit être là et on
avance on a changé récemment le ministre
de
la santé comment ça se passait avec la
précédente
et qu'est ce que vous attendez du
nouveau alors moi madame busin je la
connaissais de la haute autorité de
santé parce que je suis expert à la hs
depuis 17 ans donc j'ai eu l'occasion de
travailler que madame busin donc en fait
quand il est arrivé au ministère
s'étaient une continuité logique du
travail qu'elle faisait à la haute
autorité de santé je l'en remercie
évidemment on avait l'occasion
d'échanger lorsqu on se croisait sur
l'obésité
elle est très impliquée le président de
la république monsieur macron est
également très impliqué j'espère qu
effectivement monsieur vers on n'a pas
encore eu l'occasion de se voir demain
j'ai une grosse réunion au ministère de
la santé j'espère qu'on va être dans la
continuité dans l'intérêt de tous mais
je pense que ça sera le cas
merci beaucoup anne sophie joly d'avoir
été avec nous aujourd'hui voilà vous
l'aurez compris c'est la fin de cette
grande interview une émission que vous
pouvez d'ores et déjà retrouver en
replay et en podcast sur arte france à
points à tva très bientôt sur arte
france
[Musique]